wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
es ist wirklich unglaublich was du
geschafft hast ich weiß noch gar nicht
ob ich die prüfung bestanden habe ich
bin überzeugt ist bestanden hat
hoffentlich reicht
ich bin mir wegen des briefs den
schreiben muss nichts sicher und ich
habe angst dass ich im schriftlichen
teil meines tests zu viele fehler
gemacht habe deswegen einen fehler nicht
durchfallen du musst dir keine sorgen
machen
ich weiß nicht ob ich es schaffe mir
keine sorgen zu machen
noch drei gläser davon das problem ist
gelöst und weil beginnt dann deine
ausbildung da wirst du noch viele
prüfungen machen müssen und ich bin
gespannt auf alles was jetzt kommt
diese prüfung ist der erste schritt auf
deinem neuen weg auf niveaus weg auch
nicos welt